une découverte majeure que nous avons trouvée à l'
ombre
de la pyramide escarpée la plus ancienne pyramide
d'egypte
[musique]
la chose la plus importante que nous ayons trouvée
nous avons trouvé un temple
près d'une pyramide d'une reine à l'intérieur du
temple
un nom un nouveau nom d'une reine elle  le nom
était nit
c'était la femme et la fille du roi
titty et c'est la première fois que nous
savons
que le roi pouvait épouser sa fille
mais nous ne connaissons cette pratique que dans le
nouveau royaume mais c'est la première
fois
que nous avons des preuves  à propos du mariage
entre le roi et sa fille
dans l'ancien royaume
nous avons également trouvé 22 puits à l'intérieur des
puits étaient des cercueils et des momies
dans un puits 54 cercueils
à l'intérieur des artefacts uniques du puits nous avons
trouvé un papyrus d'
environ cinq mètres de long nous avons trouvé des statuts majeurs
toute cette découverte  réécrira l'
histoire de saqqarah dans le nouveau royaume
[Musique]
vous